hello and sorry welcome to this video
playing Grand Master at all rot this is
keith our color right yep i want a
couple of senior then see other senior
ends now started 50 years old so I'm
kind of closing in on that feels kinda
weird anyway so I'm going for the
Queen's inion want to experiment a
little bit with that opening and I don't
think our co will go for a porn sec line
with Quincy to is the most solid player
you can imagine let's see I'm going for
this now check check and a five it's an
interesting strategically um complicated
line the ship's III whom I've never seen
that move okay so i have a kind of a
standard idea Oh interesting he tricked
me but Bishop now is in trouble I did
not Wow d5 there is c5 oh wow d 6 was it
was very stupid oh my god Wow now he's
got c5 but I didn't have anything else I
so i blundered the piece oh my god i had
said this is this is a very well-known
trick but i didn't didn't see it coming
yeah like an old still continue a little
bit and queen d for yes okay this one I
need to get in c 5 at least then I've
got some kind of Center okay so if i go
see five now kicks Quincy seven books e1
looxcie aid now so I can I can play that
move
Wow what is he able to do that help I
don't understand anything here because
of what print a to maybe and tween a
tube now but I can take here and you can
also like the Queen takes Queen takes a
896 Queen B 7 I cannot trap the queen
but I can take on v3 which at least
continues the game not happy of course
but after blundering a full-piece you
can be happy of the game somehow
continues okay what now pin 24 there's
probably 95 anyway
okay so at least I've got some a little
bit of an activity it's not enough of
course but you can always hope so what
now like you five cannot Google be one
at least and that's if 95 is got 96 and
I don't have good squares unfortunately
in our latest six is also annoying let's
make some roof for my king
arkel is a very good technical player so
he should gas should manage this is this
job rather easily but still it's blitz
chess you never know so how would you do
it can I somehow get this going probably
not maybe i can bring the night over to
d6 currently sure it's nights they're
not doing that much
not threatening time I mean this with
this move
anyway to get to pawn going it won't see
it at 50 seconds huh that's not good
I know I can can I go somewhere like
94-92 move it you cannot go there and
now I can share my poor nope I I am I
need to blunder lots of stuff him to
lose but I managed okay amazon dad's mad
wasn't i wasn't even what's that so
clear anymore i don't see it right sense
that the clear win maybe it is yeah it
was it was a an instructive moment in
the opening I just had a complete can I
just made this oversight yeah this moves
I know I have to react to that move the
idea is Bishop b2 a dc-6 is ridiculous I
just forgot about Bishop b2 just forgot
about the idea it's a very typical idea
quite often white and also doing this to
prepare that I just didn't think I'd it
just didn't think actively I have to
play some D 5 or something else maybe
you look if there i don't know i can
also play but should be seven back but i
absolutely cannot play this move after
that i'm basically toast him yeah I try
it a little bit yeah actually I can win
with note c5 takes that be a six traps
the Queen a venir yet ah having it
looked pretty bad this idea taking 1c5 I
was really surprised that you did it but
I just didn't think of night I just
think thought of knight c6 I not of this
just wrap his queen ah for the bad
I am anyway so here we we struggled on
iti can take this I just played that
ridiculously badly and this disposition
is tough to win really tough to win two
I continue to use still not so easy
until i blundered blundered the rook
Chan plundering the rook is not a good
idea yeah it was a really bad game it
it's all I can say thanks for watching